أجنبي
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
يارا دالك [موسيقى
]
إجمالي الطاقات [موسيقى] أجنبي أجنبي أجنبي أجنبي
عضو فندق [موسيقى
]
[موسيقى]
شكرًا أجنبيًا
أجنبيًا
جيدًا.  لقد توصلنا إلى استنتاج مفاده أن
الدورة الفائقة ليست سوى
دورة رأس المال حيث يكون لديك استثمار واسع النطاق
وإذا فكرنا في
الدورتين الفائقتين اللتين لاحظناهما على مدار
السبعين عامًا الماضية ، حدثت إحداها بين عامي
1968 و 1980 لمدة 12 عامًا
أو أكثر  الناس على دراية بأن
أحدهما الآخر حدث من 2002 إلى
2014. ومن المفارقات أيضًا أن 12 عامًا ولكن عندما
تنظر إلى مخطط النفقات الرأسمالية العالمية مقسومًا
على الناتج المحلي الإجمالي العالمي لالتقاط
دورة Cat-Back وتراكب ذلك مع
أسعار المعادن على مدى السبعين الماضية  سنتان
يتطابقان تمامًا ، وهو ما
يخبرك حقًا بما يحدث هنا
هو أن لديك استثمارًا واسع النطاق والطريقة التي
بدأنا بها في التفكير في
الأمر هي عدم التفكير في الأمر من خلال
السلع ، ولكن فكر في الأمر من
الأسهم بدلاً من
ذلك.  في الستينيات ، والتسعينيات في العقد الأول من
القرن الحادي والعشرين ، كان الجميع مشتركًا في أنهم كانوا
اقتصادًا جديدًا كبيرًا جدًا فقاعات الأسهم كانت
50 أنيقًا في الستينيات وهي تلك
النقطة في الوقت الذي كان الاقتصاد الجديد هو Coca-Cola ،
فقد كانت العلامات التجارية مثل lvmh هي اليوم وفي
التسعينيات  لقد كان طفرة موقع الويب وفي
عام 2010 كان هذا هو المعتوه المزيف ولكن ما
فعلوه جميعًا هو أنهم خنقوا رأس المال
للاقتصاد القديم بمعنى النفط والغاز
والتعدين والمعادن والباقي لدرجة أنهم
كانوا مستثمرين للغاية عندما
ذهبت إلى  السبعينيات أو في العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين أو
حتى عشرينيات القرن العشرين ، وكل ما تطلبه الأمر كان حدث
طلب حدث طلب في عام 1968 كان
مجتمع إل بي جي العظيم ، وكان حدث الطلب في العقد الأول من القرن
الحادي والعشرين هو قبول الصين في
منظمة التجارة العالمية في حدث الطلب هذه المرة كان
حافزًا للشفاء ولكن لكن  لقد فعلوا جميعًا
نفس الشيء بسحب المخزونات استنفاد
السعة الفائضة وترك السوق
معرضة جدًا لنمو الطلب في المستقبل بشكل
جيد عندما نفكر في
عنصر الاستثمار غير المباشر على جانب العرض ، فقد
كان لديهم جميعًا نقص الاستثمار
في كشك الطلب
أم ماذا؟  سوف يجعل المرء هذا الأمر
أكثر تعقيدًا هو تراكب
السياسة البيئية الذي يجعل من
الصعب جدًا جذب رأس المال إلى
القطاع الذي تعرفه أود أن أشير
إلى أنك تعرف أسعار النفط التي تنظر إليها
أسعار المعادن كانت السلع مرتفعة كما تعلم
26 في المائة العام الماضي في العام
قبل 42 في المائة كان العائد في
أسهم الطاقة 60 ، لكن ما حدث
للنفقات الرأسمالية الحقيقية على مدار
العام الماضي انخفض في عام 2021
أيضًا ، لذلك لم نحصل على هذا
الرد في الاستثمار  التي قد
تحصل عليها عادةً ، أريد أن أضع تحذيرًا
هنا إذا عدت خلال الدورة في العقد الأول من
القرن الحادي والعشرين ، حيث تحركت الأسعار في O2 ،
ولم يأت الحد الأقصى X إلى o5 أشخاص ببساطة
لم يؤمنوا باستدامة
القصة بشكل مشابه جدًا  إلى ما هم عليه
الآن ، من الصعب كما تعلمون ولا
أعرف ما إذا كان الأمر متعلقًا بالحوكمة البيئية والاجتماعية وحوكمة الشركات أو ما إذا كان
الناس لديهم ذوق سيء في فمهم
من زيت الطهي والسلع ، دعونا لا
ننسى أن قطاع الطاقة دمر 54
سنتًا على كل دولار يتم استثماره  على مدار
العقد الماضي ، وقد ترسخ هذا الأمر في
العديد من المستثمرين ،
أجد أن ارتفاع العرض يمثل
حجة صعبة لأن السبعينيات كانت قيد
الاستثمار عبر المساحة بأكملها في العقد الأول من القرن
الحادي والعشرين قيد الاستثمار عبر
المساحة بأكملها واليوم قيد الاستثمار في
جميع أنحاء الولاية ، لذا فأنا لا أفعل ذلك.  نشتري في
العرض المتزايد ، دعنا ننتقل إلى
السؤال حول ارتفاع الطلب ،
نعم ، لقد ارتفع الطلب في عام 1968 مع
lbj's Great Society ولكن طوال
السبعينيات ، بدأ يتضاءل بالمناسبة
بالنسبة للعديد من المستمعين الذين أحب أن
أذكرهم  شخص وقعت المحاولة الأولى
لحظر نفط أوبك في عام 1967.
لم يكن هناك طلب كافٍ لإنجاحه ولم
ينجح حتى 73 بعد خمس سنوات من
مجتمع LBJ العظيم ، ماذا عن العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين
كان قبول الصين في منظمة التجارة العالمية؟
البيئة الحالية
التي تعرفها ، أود أن أشير إلى أن كوفيد
كانت أزمة عدم مساواة
وأجبرت الحكومات في جميع أنحاء العالم على
التركيز على المجموعات المحرومة ،
ونتيجة لذلك رأينا حافزًا موجهًا
إلى المنازل ذات الدخل المنخفض والأسر ذات الدخل المنخفض
تستهلك أكثر بكثير  السلع أكثر
من السلع ذات الدخل المرتفع ، ونتيجة لذلك ،
شهدنا ارتفاعًا كبيرًا في الطلب
وسيقول لي الكثير من الناس حسنًا ، لقد اختفى كل هذا
مع عدم وجود نظرة
على أوروبا ، فأنت تعلم أنها أساسًا ضريبة الأرباح
وضرائب الأرباح المفاجئة التي تجني
العائدات  من هذه الضرائب
ومنحها كإعانات للفئات ذات الدخل المنخفض من حيث
استهلاك الطاقة ، مما يجعل
صورة الطلب أقوى بكثير ، لذا
فأنت تعلم أن الناس يحبون أن يقولوا أنه لا يوجد
عنصر طلب لهذا ، نعم هناك ،
وعندما نفكر في
المعادن ، نفكر في كل شيء  أن الطلب على المركبات الكهربائية
سيكون بمثابة طفرة كبيرة في رأس المال ،
مثل ما نفكر فيه حول الصين ،
كانت الصين طفرة في الطلب على المعادن للذهاب
لبناء كل تلك المدن ، ستكون هذه المدينة بمثابة طفرة في
الطلب على الميداليات للذهاب إلى
بناء المركبات الكهربائية وإزالة الكربون في
التقنيات الخضراء هناك  مشابه جدًا
لما كانت عليه الصين في الواقع ، فنحن نجادل في أن
الطلب على النفقات الرأسمالية الخضراء هذا العقد
أكبر من الطلب على النفقات الرأسمالية خلال
سنوات الازدهار الصيني في العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين ،
ثم العقد الذي تلا ذلك كان ضعف
الصين ، لذا فقد دفعت حقًا
ضد  ليس هناك طلب على
السلع أه سيكون هناك
قدر هائل من الطلب على السلع في
المستقبل وأنت تعرف وجهة نظرك الأخرى
حول ارتفاع الأسعار ، فلنلقِ نظرة على ما
فعلته الأسعار على مدار
العامين الماضيين منذ أن كنا ندعو
إلى  دورة السلع الفائقة التي تعرفها أن الزيت
AO يرتفع بحوالي 2X ومن
الواضح أن المعادن ارتفعت مرتين مرة أخرى ، دعنا
نعود إلى العوائد من السلع في عام 2021
مقابل 42 في المائة وفي عام 2022
كانوا 26 أرقامًا كبيرة
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
I  أود أن أشير إلى أن
السلع المنبوذة
التي تعرفها ، دعنا نأخذ الفحم
والتبغ
لننظر إلى أسعارهما الآن
حيث كانت الآن كما تعلم
سابقًا ، لقد قفزت للتو إلى القمر
بسبب قلة الاستثمار في التوريد ، لذا
من قبلك  تعلم أنك ستحصل على
طلب إزالة الكربون ، عليك
إلقاء نظرة على كل من جانب العرض وجانب
الطلب ، ولم يستثمر أحد في الفحم
ولم يستثمر أحد في التبغ وأنت تعلم أن
الطلب كان معتدلاً في كل من هذه
السلع
ولكن الأسعار ارتفعت بشكل كبير.
بسبب أطروحة قيد الاستثمار
ولكني أريد أيضًا أن أتحدث عن
أم على جانب الطلب
وأنت تعلم أننا ننظر إلى
طلبات النفط التي من المحتمل أن تصل إلى
أعلى مستوى جديد على الإطلاق هذا العام ،
وأنت تعرف الطلب البارد ، نعم نحن  إعادة
تحويل الطاقة ولكن ما
انتقلنا إليه العام الماضي كان
الفحم ، ولذا عندما ننظر إلى ذلك ، فأنت تعلم
بالمناسبة أنني أريد أن أؤكد أنني
مؤمن كبير أننا بحاجة إلى القيام بشيء حيال
تغير المناخ وهو أمر
مهم للغاية ولكنه حالي  لا
تؤدي السياسات إلى انخفاض الطلب الذي
توقعه الكثيرون
ونجادل في نهاية المطاف في اتخاذ مثل
سعر الكربون أو ضريبة الكربون لجعله
مكلفًا للغاية لدرجة أنك تعرف أن الأشخاص لا
ينخرطون في هذه الأنشطة ولكن أعتقد
أنه من المهم أن  تذكر ، نعم ،
نعتقد أنك ستشهد نجاحًا في الطلب ولكنك تعلم
في أقرب وقت أنك
ستبطئ معدلات نمو الطلب في
منتصف هذا العقد ولن ترى
أن ذروة الطلب على النفط تعني الانقلاب
حتى  أوائل الثلاثينيات من القرن الماضي ، هذه
فترة طويلة من الآن
وليس لدينا الاستثمار
مما يعني أن لديك طلب يسير في
هذا الاتجاه ، مما
يعني أنك في عجز هيكلي
ماذا لو كان النفط أو المعادن
و  دعونا لا ننسى عندما يكون لديك
طفرات رأس المال الكبيرة هذه ، فهي محفزة جدًا
لبقية أنها يمكن أن توفر حافزًا
لبقية الاقتصاد الذي
يجب عليك بعد ذلك الحصول على كل النفط لأنك تعرف
كل الأنشطة الجارية لبناء
هذا  أه تعلم أن هذا هو السبب في أنني أعتقد
أنه من السابق لأوانه التسبب في الدعوة إلى
تأبين النفط الآن جيف ويل
أم إنه
بالضبط ما يجب أن يحدث فكر
في هذا عندما تكون أسعار الفائدة صفرية
ما الذي يركز عليه المستثمرون على
فرص النمو طويلة الأجل  في
تشفير Sky Investments ، كان كل ذلك هو ما
كان التركيز عليه هو ما تعرفه في
أه في 2010 أو تعرف التسعينيات
ما الذي ركزوا عليه على
ازدهار.com على المدى الطويل أو ما الذي
ركزوا عليه في الستينيات  نمو العلامة التجارية لشركة Coca-Cola
في هذه المجالات ، لذا فإن آفاق النمو على المدى الطويل
هي التركيز مع
معدلات فائدة بنسبة صفر في المائة في ما
تخبرك به أسعار الفائدة المرتفعة أنك تجلب
التركيز على المدى القريب إلى
التركيز على المدى القصير بطريقة أخرى لتقول
إنه أعلى  تجعل أسعار الفائدة وضع
بعض الشيء في الأرض مربحًا أكثر
مما تعلمه عند التفكير في
فرص التكنولوجيا طويلة الأجل ، طريقة أخرى
للقول بأن أسعار الفائدة المرتفعة
تخبرك أنك بحاجة إلى القيام باستثمارات
في أنشطة قصيرة الأجل ،
كما تعلم بالمناسبة  المهمات هي نعم ،
أنت تعرف إلى حد كبير أنك تعرف أننا
جادلنا بنسبة 4.3 في المائة العام الماضي لأن
الناس لا يركزون على 20
50 من الانبعاثات وليس الانبعاثات على المدى القريب والشيء
نفسه عندما
ترتفع أسعار الفائدة معدلات فائدة أعلى يعني أنك
بحاجة إلى القيام  الخيارات وعندما تتخذ
قرارات عليك أن تفكر في ما
يجب علينا فعله اليوم لإزالة عنق الزجاجة من
النظام للسماح بالنمو ولذا
أعتقد أن هذا السؤال هو طريقة أخرى
للتفكير يفقد النقطة
طريقة أخرى للتفكير فيها  هذه
معدلات فائدة أعلى تجعل قصة التقنية طويلة الأجل هذه
ليست ممتعة للغاية ولكنها تجعل
زراعة المعادن على المدى القريب في
هذه الأصول المملة للاقتصاد القديم أكثر
إثارة للاهتمام في بيئة ذات معدل أعلى
ودعونا نفكر فيما حدث في
معدلات أعلى في السبعينيات.  والمزيد من
الاستثمار ، فأنت تعرف ما حدث في
العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين ، معدلات أعلى من الاستثمار ،
ويمكنك حتى التفكير في
معدلات أعلى تعني عائدًا أفضل في
العالم المادي مقارنة
بالعالم المالي وهذا هو العالم الذي نتجه
نحو
أعمال جيفرسون
I  قد تجادل أنك تريد امتلاك الثلاثة
في الواقع ، فأنت تنظر إلى أداة استثمارية
مثل مؤشر سلعة بلومبيرج B المشترك ،
فهي متساوية جدًا في
جميع هذه العناصر حيث لا يتعين علينا إجراء
مكالمة قطاعية ،
وأنت تعلم أن هذا هو الشيء
أحيانًا  تبدو المعادن أفضل في الوقت الحالي ، أعتقد أن
المعادن تبدو أفضل في الوقت الحالي من
الطاقة ، ولكن من المحتمل أن تبدو الطاقة
أفضل من المعادن من ستة إلى 12 شهرًا من
الآن ،
لذا إذا كنت تفكر في الاحتفاظ على
المدى الطويل بامتلاك Horizon
لشيء مثل مؤشر سلعة متنوع
مثل مؤشر bcom الذي أعتقد أنه
وسيلة أكثر حكمة بكثير في فبراير ،
نعم حالتنا الأساسية هي أننا من المحتمل أن
نرى حوالي 600000 برميل يوميًا من
الإمدادات المفقودة بسبب الاحتكاكات في
عدم القدرة على إعادة توجيه المنتجات التي
تعيد توجيه النفط الخام أمر سهل نسبيًا يمكنك
العثور عليه  ناقلة خردة في مكان ما في
العالم تحصل على التأمين الصيني تملأه ،
وانقله إلى مكان ما مثل الهند ، وإنشاء
المنتجات وإعادة المنتجات
إلى أوروبا أو الولايات المتحدة ، لا يمكنك القيام بهذه
الحيلة مع المنتجات لأنها
تعرفها بالفعل  استخدام
المنتجات النهائية ونتيجة لذلك ليس لدينا
وسائل النقل ، سيكون من
الأصعب بكثير إعادة توجيه المنتجات كما
رأينا مع النفط الخام وبالتالي نتوقع أن
نرى الاحتكاكات تؤدي إلى
انخفاض حوالي 600000 برميل يوميًا  في سلاسل التوريد
أم
أجنبية
بينما نتطلع إلى فترة شتاء 2024 ،
نعتقد أنك ستستعيد
ضيقها مرة أخرى في فترة الشتاء تلك باستثناء
شتاء آخر دافئ
ولكن أعتقد أن النقطة الأكثر أهمية
للنفط والمعادن وكل شيء
هو أوروبا  مدرج الآن قبل أن يواجه
مشاكل ، يمكن أن يصل إلى حوالي
عام وأنا تعلم أن النقطة المهمة الأخرى
التي لم تذكرها
سأضعها فوق روسيا وهي الصين ، ما كان
أكبر حدث حدث
للسلع في عام 2022  كانت الصين ليست
روسيا الصين
أكبر مستهلك للسلع الأساسية في العالم ،
وأكبر مستورد للنفط في العالم أو
ثاني أكبر اقتصاد في العالم ،
حيث كانت خسارة الطلب من الصين
ثلاثة أضعاف الخسائر المحتملة
من روسيا ، ولذا عندما نفكر في ذلك
ما هو أكبر حدث يحدث
للسلع في الاقتصاد العالمي
الآن هنا اليوم هو نعم
بالعودة إلى أوروبا ، سوف
يسحب أوروبا على طول مزود أوروبا الكبير
للسلع الرأسمالية إلى الصين ،
وبالتالي من خلال إزالة قيود الطاقة عن
أوروبا ، أنت تفتح الفرصة
للصين ليس فقط لتكوين قوة
محليًا وبقية
العالم هناك ولكن أيضًا كما تعلم تساعد في
الاستفادة من السعة الزائدة في أوروبا
التي تم إغلاقها سابقًا بسبب
مشاكل الطاقة ، لذا فإن
التوقعات هي المدرج  في أوروبا في الصين على
مدار الستة 12 شهرًا القادمة يعد أمرًا
إيجابيًا للغاية
[موسيقى]
برامج جيف كاري مين جولدمان ساكس